When I need to build something using
materials I shouldn't be breathing in,
I naturally put on a dust mask and
safety goggles.
Just like that, our tools can save
us web developers from disaster.
Now, of course, you won't accidentally
amputate a finger from bad JavaScript,
but you can make any of countless
mistakes that can result in your
site being unusable for a lot of users.
Here's the thing.
Tools aren't perfect either, but
their never tired, never lack
concentration, and don't have an ego.
By utilizing your build and
editor tools,
you can quite heavily improve
the quality output of your coding.
Let's talk about the numerous
ways to get there.